several years ago I got to be very
interested in honeybees and the
extraordinary talent that they have for
dancing they're better dancers than us
they've been doing it a lot longer and
they certainly seem to have danced as
their culture to a greater extent than
probably any other species so I got to
thinking about whether there was a way
to work with honeybees collaboratively
making use of their dance in a way that
would choreograph it as we do amongst
ourselves for human audiences so what I
did was I studied extensively the
language of bees the language by which
they indicate to others where flowers
are to be found so that others can then
to go and find those flowers and in the
process of pollinating them bring back
more nectar or more pollen for the hive
I worked out where hives were in the
city of San Francisco relative to places
that I might plant flowers and then
mapped out specifically where the
flowers should be planted as a way of
choreographing of marking in their own
language what sorts of moves might
follow others in a way that
aesthetically speaking to me at least
seemed like it might appeal to them all
of this was done with total freedom as
far as the bees were concerned to follow
my suggestions or not and also without
any sort of obligation to perform for us
that is to say that I mapped it out and
then working with some collaborators
went and planted the flowers and I made
a map which was available for human
audiences if they were interested in
seeing what the bees were up to but
there were no cameras in the hives there
was no way in which we would be able to
watch what they were doing it wasn't
some sort of a minstrel show it wasn't
some sort of a performance for us it was
a performance that was offered to the
bees for their own amusement for their
own
interest their own edification such that
then they might find the aesthetic in
their dance and move beyond simply using
dance in a utilitarian way for finding
where flowers were - making that an
integral part of their culture at the
level of art in our culture I often
start any project by asking a naive
question so naive that most likely you
ask these sorts of questions when you
were a child but at a certain age you
learned that these were not appropriate
or even if you ask them to yourself
you've never really followed through to
try to see what would happen if you were
to do something that was kind of
patently absurd in the case of the
honeybee ballet I had the question of
whether I could choreograph a ballet for
another species communicating across
species in a way that might facilitate a
greater deeper relationship between us
especially at a time where colonnaded
collapse disorder was effectively
through our use of pesticides destroying
their habitat was there a way in which
we could find some sort of a common
ground and dance is such an essential
part of what we do as humans that I
thought that perhaps I could offer that
to the bees as something that they could
participate in as well so asking that
question could i choreograph a ballet
for another species for honeybees I
don't know any of them I've never talked
to them I know only about them as much
as I've ever read but realizing that
their language is incredibly
sophisticated arguably as sophisticated
as ours according to their culture
according to their needs that I could
find that common ground and once I had
figured out the basic way in which to
try to communicate with
using their own language using using
flowers I realize that there was a way
in which I could pursue this rather
naive question not for the sake of
reaching an answer a solution that would
resolve this in some definitive way but
rather as a way of continuing my
exploration that we could continue to
think about what sort of relationship we
have with other species how our culture
and theirs have commonalities because we
all come from the same place and we all
need to get to the same place so how do
we do that
the bigger question of how we live
within a world that is as complex as
ours in harmony with other species is
one that gets addressed through this
much smaller more naive question of
asking what would it mean what would it
take to choreograph a ballet for
honeybees